[Applause]
all right I could not think of a way to
enter this so we are jumping right into
it I'm gonna do something I haven't done
before on this channel and that is
basically a review of cosplay item now
the thing I'm gonna be talking about
today is a 12th doctor coat and now this
is specifically a replication of the
coat Peter Capaldi the 12th doctor wore
in series 10 because he had several as
many of the modern doctors do if you're
wondering why I'm looking like this it's
because well all I got was the coat so I
had to throw together my own stuff for
what's gonna go under it so we'll see
that in a minute
now before I actually start to show you
this thing we'll get into specifics in a
bit this full disclosure was provided to
me at no cost by the company cause daddy
which is where this can be purchased and
it was given to me for the purposes of
me making a review video I did guarantee
them that I would make a review video
once I found it there once I received it
there was no guarantee of a positive
review video nor did they give me any
specific pieces of copy that I need to
put in the video to describe the product
everything I'm about to say are my own
words but the full disclosure is I did
not actually pay for this they sent it
to me so now that will clear on that
so nobody shouts collusion at me let's
uh let's see how the sucker looks
[Music]
[Music]
haha not bad right
okay so let's go over this thing so
first of all hopefully this will kind of
show up this is very soft I don't I
don't know the exact material I should
have checked that but again I'm not
really a professional at this but this
this has the velvet type finish you can
see between the way that it catches
light and the way that it actually feels
it does have that finish on it and it
has the blue lining on the inside and it
does have you saw me pull the sonic
screwdriver from it it's got an inside
pocket which is well sized for that
purpose and the lining is very very soft
very smooth like this this thing this is
comfortable this material this fabric I
could wear this without the hood without
like I'm not going to do this but I
could wear this without a shirt on and
it would still be comfortable to wear
it's not a scratchy abrasive material in
any way you noticed you probably spotted
right away how nice these suckers look
and they're pretty securely on there as
well
and if I will I rather enjoyed partially
because like I rather always liked the
wake of Hollywood unbuttoned either the
vest of the coat so I actually really
like how easily I can one-handed Lee
King they the buttons fit really well
into there but everything's just loose
enough that it's really easy to do that
way
and something that I didn't realize
until I got it on and this is cool these
on the side it's not uncommon when you
get these along the side of a coat that
they're decorative that this is all sewn
shut and they're just there that is not
the case here if you wanted to you could
actually unbutton these loosen them you
can roll the sleeves of this up for the
purposes of cosplay I'm not sure
that there is a reason to do that out of
the game or did that in show but I just
I like the fact that you can it's it is
much less rigid in terms of what you can
do with it then a lot of cosplay things
that I've gotten now like I in terms of
cosplay things that I've bought over the
years I have bought things for usually
one of two purposes conventions videos
and burlesque numbers and more often
than not I will go with thee not quite
the cheapest but slightly better than
the cheapest option so I'm kind of used
to the compromises you get when you
don't spend a ton of money on that
having been said this code for as nice
as it is is not as expensive like this
code especially for something as
accurate as screen accurate as this is
at a guess I would have expected to pay
upwards of 100 bucks for this and it's
not that it's incredibly reasonably
priced yes cause daddy yes I will help
I'll plug it it's a good thing and there
is there is a you know links and
everything down there and they've got a
lot of Doctor Who stuff it's it's all
quite nice about the only thing that I
would well no there's two things that
I'll note about this I'm not sure I
personally consider either needs to be
outright criticisms but they are things
worth noting the first is is that this
fabric I can already tell this is gonna
pick up loose hairs like you wouldn't
believe
so if you've got a dog a cat or any
shedding pet you're gonna you're gonna
have to deal with that it's gonna cling
to you I can just kind of tell that and
the other thing is and again not
necessarily criticism but as is often
the case with cosplay coats as good as
it looks in as good as the the material
is and like it's it's funny it there is
actually even a little bit of a stretch
to it to the point that I kind of like
done this a little bit to it and I
thought I'd ripped it because of the
amount of give
but now it actually is actually has a
little bit of stretch m to it which is
also quite nice but anyway the point
that I was getting is for as nice as the
out of material in the lining is it
doesn't have it's not insulated so as
nice as the coat is you're actually not
going to be able to use it to ward off
the cold very well now that might seem
like a weird thing except you know I'm
the weirdo who totally would go to the
store in his Doctor Who coat if it was
warm enough to do so I actually I feel
the same way about the the Tenth Doctor
coat that I have I love that coat but
it's not thick so if it's actually
chilly enough that I need a coat it
doesn't do the job and that would
probably be the case here but again
unless you're a weirdo like me that
might not even really be a criticism but
I gotta say this this just this is
really nice like the the look and the
feel of it because so often you are
losing one of two things when you are
getting cosplay items that aren't custom
and you aren't paying an arm and a leg
for either they don't look quite right
but they don't feel too bad to wear or
they look great and are uncomfortable as
hell some of the Wonder Woman stuff I've
gotten at various points fell under that
core category like I had to I had to
actually get different stuff from from
earlier versions of some of the things
that I have with that so that bad is
usually the compromise but this is
comfortable it's well fitted like I said
it has that little bit of give not
enough that I'm not gonna say that it's
stretchy that like you could misjudge
your size and be fine but it sort of
does allow for that wiggle room between
sizes where if you're someone who tends
to fall in between say large and
extra-large like honestly I tend to then
it gives you that little bit of
reassurance which I again would not have
expected off this I'm I'm quite happy
with this and I'm now in a conundrum
because I've got Gallifrey one coming up
next month that I'm going to and I was
all set because I had three Doctor Who
pieces of cosplay I had tenth doctor at
13th doctor at eleventh so I like great
three days of the convention three
outfits now I've got another one and it
looks great and I'm gonna want to wear
it now I have to figure out which one of
the other three I'm not gonna do nice
problem to have but oh goodness sake so
I think I'll wrap it up on that one yeah
cause daddy this is really nice
and I hope they'll send me stuff again
but even if they don't yeah I'd take a
look at their site certainly I feel like
if this is their standard base level of
quality then it's certainly gonna be
more reliable than Amazon you order
cosplay items off of Amazon it's a
crapshoot but this this is nice so thank
you to them hope you folks found this
interesting and amusing and didn't I
didn't come off like a complete and
utter shell probably did but this is a
nice coat so let me ask you this what
character from Doctor Who would you want
to cosplay as which doctor which
companion which version of the master
and that like I'm not gonna say like
you'll find it on cuz that they've got a
lot you could I know you folks you'll
think of stuff that they don't have but
set the set the the folks who sent me
this aside just what is a character that
you would really want to cosplay or you
really want to see somebody cosplay that
you've never seen before I've seen some
awesome Doctor Who cosplays when I was
at terrific on there was it awesome 12th
doctor there was an amazing Davros there
was a Dalek that was moving around
there's some good stuff I've seen and
I'm excited for what I'll see you at
Gallifrey 1 what do you
see or what do you want to do whatever
your thoughts are drop them on down in
the comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do you know all the stuff
subscribe like comment patreon that's in
the description below underneath all the
cause daddy stuff you know you can keep
scrolling down and support me haha but
you also don't have to do any of that
cuz end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]